Cancer is a creepy and mysterious thing in the process of trying to
understand it, to get better at killing eggs,
we discovered a biological paradox that remains unsolved to this day.
Large animals seem to be immune to cancer, which doesn't make any sense.
The bigger being the more cancer.
It should have to understand why we first need to take a look at the
nature of cancer itself.
Our cells are protein.
Robots made out of hundreds of millions of parts guided only by
chemical reactions.
They create and dismantle structures sustain a metabolism to gain energy
or make almost perfect copies of themselves.
We call these complex chemical reactions pathways.
They are biochemical networks upon networks,
intertwined and stacked on top of each other.
Most of them can barely be comprehended by a single human mind,
and yet they function perfectly until they don't
with billions of trillions of reactions happening in thousands of networks over
many years. The question is not if something will go wrong,
but when tiny mistakes add up until the grandiose machinery gets
corrupted to prevent this from getting out of hand,
our cells have killed switches that make them commit suicide,
but these kill switches are not infallible.
If they fail a cell can turn into a cancer cell.
Most of them are slain by the immune system very quickly,
but this is a numbers game and give it enough time.
A cell would accrue enough mistakes slip by are noticed and begin making more of
itself. All animals have to deal with this problem. In general,
the cells of different animals are the same size.
The cells of a mouse aren't smaller than yours.
It just has fewer cells in total and a shorter lifespan, fewer cells,
and a short life means a lower chance of things going wrong, or cells mutated,
or at least it should mean that humans live about 50 times longer and have
1000 times more cells than mice.
Yet the rate of cancer is basically the same in humans and in mice,
even waiter blue whales with about 3000 times more cells than humans don't seem
to get cancer at all. Ready? This is Petos paradox.
The baffling realization that large animals have much,
much less cancer than they should scientists think there are two main ways of
explaining the paradox evolution and tumors solution
one evolve or become a blob of cancer.
As multicellular beings developed a 600 million years ago,
animals became bigger and bigger,
which added more and more cells and hence more and more chances that cells could
be corrupted.
So the collective had to invest in better and better cancer defenses.
The ones that did not died out, but cancer doesn't just happen.
It's a process that involves many individual mistakes and mutations in several
specific genes within the same cell.
These genes are called proto-oncogenes and when they mutate it's bad
news. For example, with the right mutation,
a cell will lose its ability to kill itself another mutation,
and it will develop the ability to hide another.
And it will send out calls for resources and other one,
and it will multiply quickly. These oncagenes have an antagonist though.
Tumor suppressor genes.
They prevent these critical mutations from happening or order the cell to kill
itself. If they decided to beyond repair,
it turns out that large animals have an increased number of them because of this
and different cells require more mutations than my cells to develop a tumor.
They are not immune, but more resilient.
This adaption probably comes with a cost in some form,
but researchers still aren't sure what it is.
Maybe tumor suppresses make elephants age quicker later in life or slow down how
quickly injuries heal. We don't know yet,
but the solution to the paradox may actually be something different hyper tumors
solution to hyper tumors. Yes,
rarely hyper tumors are named after hyper parasites.
The parasites of parasites, hyper tumors, other tumors of tumors.
Cancer can be thought of as a breakdown in cooperation.
Normally cells work together to form structures like organs, tissue,
or elements of the immune system,
but cancer cells are selfish and only work for their own short-term benefit.
If they're successful, they form tumors, huge cancer collectives.
That can be very hard to kill. Making a tumor is hard work though.
Millions or billions of cancer cells multiply rapidly,
which requires a lot of resources and energy.
The amount of nutrients they can steal from the body becomes the limiting factor
for growth.
So the tumor cells trick the body to build new blood vessels directly to the
tumor to feed the thing, killing ism.
And here the nature of cancer cells may become their own undoing.
Cancer cells are inherently unstable and so they can continue to mutate
some of them faster than their buddies. If they do this for a while,
at some point,
one of the copies of the copies of the original cancer cell might suddenly think
of itself as an individual again, and stop cooperating,
which means just like the body,
the original tumor suddenly becomes an enemy fighting for the same scarce,
nutrients and resources.
So the Nudie mutated cells can create a hyper tumor instead
of helping. They cut off the blood supply to their former buddies,
which will stop and kill the original cancer cells.
Cancer is killing cancer. This process can repeat over and over.
And this may prevent cancer from becoming a problem for a large organism.
It is possible that large animals have more of these hyper tumors than we
realize they might just not become big enough to notice, which makes sense.
A two gram tumor is 10% of a mouse's body weight.
One it's less than 0.002% of a human and
2e-06% of a blue whale.
All three tumors require the same number of cell divisions and have the same
number of cells.
So an old blue whale might be filled with tiny cancers and just not care.
There are other proposed solutions to Peter's paradox,
such as different metabolic rates or different Salita architecture.
But right now we just don't know, scientists are working on the problem,
figuring out how large animals are so resilient to one of the most deadly
diseases we know could open the path to new therapies and treatments.
Cancer has always been a challenge today.
We are finally beginning to understand it. And by doing so one day,
we might finally overcome it.
This video was sponsored by you. If you want to help us make more,
you can do so by supporting us on Patrion or getting one of the beautiful things
we've made like our space Explorer notebook with infographic pages and unique
grids to inspire your creativity or an infographic poster bundle,
or the very comfy coats cause aren't hoodie. Or if you missed it the first time,
the second run of our gratitude journal,
we put a lot of time and love into our much because just like with our videos,
we only want to put things into the world that we feel good about coats.
Cassandra is a project that by rights shouldn't really work videos.
Like the one you just watched take months to finish.
And we're only able to put in so much time because of your direct support,
because you watch and share. And because you care, thank you for watching.